SPEAKER: With over 300
sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Machine Learning Made
Easy with Kubeflow
and Elastifile,
then stay tuned because
here's the rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Machine learning is an
incredibly useful approach
to automating tasks with data.
But how do you bring it to
multi-cloud hybrid environments
as an entire stack?
Applying it is about more
than just the algorithms.
It's also about the
infrastructure, the data,
and all the other components.
You want your machine
learning to be composable,
so it accommodates all the
data science tools out there.
You want portability,
so it's easy to go
from prototyping
models on your laptop
to running them
unchanged in production.
You want it to
scale effortlessly
from your small data prototype
to your huge data pipelines.
You know what's really good
at composability, portability,
and scalability?
Containers and Kubernetes.
Except if a data
scientist who wants to use
machine learning on Kubernetes.
There's so many things that
have to be an expert in first.
They need a second
black belt in addition
to their machine learning one.
Enter Kubeflow, the
cloud-native machine
learning platform built
on Kubernetes to take
care of the entire stack.
Kubeflow's mission is to
make it easy for everyone
to develop, deploy, and
manage portable distributed
machine learning on Kubernetes.
And that means everyone, no
extra black belts needed.
Kubeflow gives
you the components
you need for machine learning
right out of the box--
Jupyter notebooks, distributed
training, model serving,
examples, plus customizable
case net packaging
that lets you add your own.
But what about the data?
App portability needs
data portability.
Well, that's what
Elastifile's for.
It gives you one-click setup and
straightforward sync strategies
all without having to
rewrite your applications.
If your app can use POSIX, NFS,
or standard block object store,
you can use Elastifile.
So Elastifile plus
Kubeflow means
you have everything you need
for truly portable machine
learning.
There is a mountain
of things to take care
of if you do it on your own.
Why not take the
ski lift instead?
In the full talk, you'll
see demos of Kubeflow
and Elastifile in action.
And what's that I'm seeing here?
You can deploy Kubeflow with
a one-step script included
in the download, and that's
thanks to Kubeflow 0.2,
which we've just announced.
The latest version
gives you added bonuses
like advanced tooling,
including H2O as a platform,
and really powerful
hyperparameter
tuning with Katib.
We also have platform
integrations including
autoscaling based
on job submission,
cloud-specific
accelerators and VMs,
and data exfiltration
prevention.
Data science is poised to
revolutionize every industry,
and Kubeflow is helping
by giving everyone
a single environment to do
reproducible, production-ready
machine learning without
having to know all the gory
behind the scenes details.
And the momentum is incredible.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]